das muss man sich mal vorstellen sie
strahlen im sichtbaren licht mit einer
leuchtkraft die bis zu zehn euro für
zimmer größer ist als die der sonne
das ist 100 millionen mal heller kaum zu
glauben war auch die rede ist vom kasan
das sind die zentren von aktiven
galaxien und bis heute haben wir mehrere
tausend solcher quattara entdeckt sie
sind die hellsten bekannten objekte in
unserem kosmos und das paradoxe es sind
schwarze löcher moment clixoom science
fiction hier gibt es täglich spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal nur
dann verpasst er kein video herzlich
willkommen
und vielen dank für euren
themenvorschlag den ihr mir über
whatsapp geschickt habt den link zur
whatsapp findet der in der video
beschreibung da gibt es die links zu den
videos schon vor der veröffentlichung
auf youtube 1960 hatten forschungsteams
rätselhafte radio quellen haben immer
aufgespürt die genau wie sterne
radiowellen ins all schicken
doch es konnte sich nicht um sterne
handeln denn dafür waren sie viel zu
weit weg das was die signale aussandte
war also entweder extrem nicht schwach
oder aber unsichtbar
1962 hatte man dann bessere instrumente
am start und den forschungsteams gelangt
ist doch etwas zu erkennen also doch
schwach leuchtende sterne jedenfalls
unvorstellbar weit weg von uns das licht
hatte mehrere milliarden jahre zu
unserer erde gebraucht und so konnte es
sich eigentlich nicht um einen stern
handeln denn diesen hätte man aus solch
einer entfernung gar nicht sehen können
ein riesiges rätsel für astronomen und
astronomen weltweit die große frage also
was steckt wirklich hinter diesen
mysteriösen objekten fest stand
zumindest schon mal ihren namen getauft
hatte man die kosmische objekte quasi
abgeleitet von quasi stella es brauchte
noch einige zeit bis bessere teleskope
entwickelt worden waren
die dann endlich die auflösung des
rätsels mit sich brachten quasare sind
die kerne von galaxien die besonders
viel radio strahlung aussenden konkret
gesagt sind fassade die kerne von
aktiven galaxien anders als unsere
milchstraße die so gut wie gar nicht
aktives erst ganze 36 jahre später
konnte eine würz galaxie der quasare
fotografiert werden das gelang den
weltraum teleskop hubble und machte
somit noch einmal deutlicher dass es
sich bei den kosten
objekten um die helden kerne von
galaxien an theoretischen physikerinnen
und physiker erkannten schnell dass die
unfassbare leuchtkraft der kasachen
nicht mit der thermonuklearen fusion wie
es bei sternen abläuft zu erklären es
stattdessen sorgen schwarze löcher dafür
dass fassade heller leuchten als
milliarden von sternen
ein wenig paradox diese sitze in der
mitte von großen galaxien und sind
supermassereiche etwa so schwer wie ein
paar millionen sterne
doch das allein erzeugt noch nicht die
unfassbare leuchtkraft der quasare sind
ja schwarze löcher waren erst ihre
kombination mit großen gaswolken zu
finden sind diese überall in einer
galaxie besonders gehäuft aber
tatsächlich in ihren zentren wenn sich
solch eine gaswolke dann einem schwarzen
loch nähert bewegt sie sich zunächst um
dieses herum in spiralförmigen bahnen
wandern die gas teilchen immer weiter
aus dass noch zu und fallen irgendwann
hinein eine scheibe aus staub und gas um
gibt also das schwarze loch und leuchtet
dabei extrem hell wird aufgeheizt durch
diese bewegung die akkretionsscheibe
dafür sorgen zwei phänomene zum einen
die wechselwirkung der teilchen mit dem
magnetfeld des schwarzen lochs und zum
anderen die ganze energie die die
teilchen auf ihren spiral bahnen
verlieren eben sich aufheizen und so ins
all abgeben und so leuchtet die scheibe
um das schwarze loch herum extrem hell
obwohl es selbst kein licht abgibt nicht
das komplette gas wird dann in das
schwarze loch gewogen zwei große ströme
werden entlang der magnetfeldlinien ins
all geschleudert und zwar mit sehr hoher
geschwindigkeit diese sogenannten jets
können unvorstellbare millionen
lichtjahre lang sein und das ist auch
die erklärung dafür dass sehr aktive
galaxien mit starken mazan in ihrem
zentrum weniger sterne hervorbringen
schließlich ist dafür nach einiger zeit
nicht mehr genug von den benötigten gas
vorhanden
im vergangenen jahr 2017 hat ein us
forschungsthemen übrigens den bislang
entferntes und was war überhaupt
entdeckt sein licht benötigt mehr als 13
milliarden jahre bis zur erde indem
galaxie kern befindet sich ein schwarzes
loch mit 800 millionen sonnenmassen
dieser fund liefert der fachwelt viele
spannende informationen
zu der frühen geschichte unseres
universums denn es ist ja bekannt seit
dem urknall vor rund 13 8 milliarden
jahren dehnt sich das universum aus und
damit natürlich auch das licht das von
solchen weit entfernten objekten zur
erde kommt physikalisch gesehen
verschiebt sich die wellenlänge des
lichts damit und zwar in den roten
bereich somit können experten und
expertinnen berechnet wie lange das sich
gebraucht hat um die erde zu erreichen
bei diesem weit entfernten kasan waren
es wohl 13,1 milliarden jahre
das entspricht einer rotverschiebung von
7,54 ziemlich krass also denn die
aufnahmen des galaxie kerns zeigen in
somit also wie er 690 millionen jahre
nach dem urknall ausgesehen hat ein
super spannender blick in die
vergangenheit also und nicht wird das
war sache sind auch enorm praktisch für
uns im international series
referenzsystem einem koordinatensystem
für sternen und planeten werden sie als
referenzpunkte genutzt wenn sie sind
nicht nur enorm hell und gut zu sehen
sondern scheinen sich von der erde aus
gesehen kaum zu bewegen
natürlich bewegen sie sich doch doch wir
bekommen hier aufgrund ihrer entfernung
kaum etwas davon mit wow ja es gibt ja
schon ihre phänomene da draußen und wir
berichten hier täglich darüber wenn er
kein video zu diesem und zu allen
anderen dem verpassen wollt dann
abonniert kriegs um auch auf englisch
denn auch da gibt es immer wieder
videopremieren dafür einfach
draufklicken und darunter geht es weiter
mit exciting discovery monster galaxy
has more star sven wilke way
bis bald hoffentlich auch auf dem
englischen kanal zu tun
stay tuned